الى ما تشير الى مواصله واستمرار هذه
العمليات من قبل الاحتلال تحديدا في طول
كرع
يعني حقيقه طولكرم تتعرض منذ فتره طويله
لعمليات اقتحامات سباق خلال ساعات الليل
او خلال ساعات النهار بدا
مطارده مجموعات مسلحه انطلقت في الفتره
الاخيره وحملت مجموعه اسم مجموعه
عاده ما تكون هذه المجموعات خلال ساعات
الليل وحتى في ساعات المغرب
مواقع اسرائيليه قريبه من مدينه طولكرم
الصباح
يعني
لها عقد استشها
انهما هما من قامت عمليه اطلاق نار ثلاث
سيارات للمستوطنين
على الاراضي قريه الى الجنوب الشرقي من
مدينه
المستوطنين
بجراح وحلال
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعلى ذلك تواصل حسن
لحظه قوات الاحتلال محافظه هذه القريه
اغلقت كافه مداخلها بيتوافذ الترابيه
ومكعبات
ما يدري هو طبيعي على جرائم الاحتلال
المتحكمه الدوليه وخاصه الفائده قدر
عدنان
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهذه العمليه عمليه
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي احتلال اليوميه في مختلف
المحافظات محافظات الدفع الغربيه التي
تتعرض يوميا لعمليات اقتحام وعمليات من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
طيب هذا يعني ان لا حدود لمثل هذه
العمليات وان مثل هذه الملاحقات
نشهد منها المزيد في الايام القادمه
فلسطين
موجود
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كما تؤكد ايضا دائما
ارتقاء الشهداء
بانها مقاومه مستمره ومتدخل
عمليات مقاومه
تقوم به هذه المجموعات ايضا من
خلال العديد من المواقع هذا رد فعل طبيعي
كلما زاد الاحتلال امانه العمليات قتل
لابد فعل الشباب الفلس